but I sort of argue that what's
happening isn't religion is becoming
more scientific or secular irrational
the market is becoming an a mystical
object of worship the market is becoming
sanctified hi I'm Nicholas be with
Reason TV and today we're talking with
Chris layman he's the author of the
provocative and powerful new book the
money cult capitalism Christianity and
the unmaking of the American Dream which
is aimed in parts squarely at
libertarian beliefs about the liberating
effects of less a fair capitalism and
individualism Chris is also the editor
of the Baffler a magazine that in its
early days claim the mantle of HL
Mencken and its crusade to inject the
left-wing understanding of politics
culture and ideas into public discourse
Chris thanks for talking to us thanks
for having me
talk about Joel Osteen the hugely
popular television person with whom you
start your book uh-huh how does he
exemplify what you see as a perversion
or at least a misguided vision of
Protestant Christianity and the pursuit
of Mammon Joel Osteen for people who may
not be familiar as a pastor of the
40,000 plus Lakewood congregation in
Houston Texas he is probably the most
successful best-known pastor and pulpit
order in America today and certainly the
leading light extolling the prosperity
gospel and then the prosperity gospel is
basically if you are right with God
money will God you know reward you and
there are lots of ways in which they
extol and instantiate this belief if
Osteen comes out of what's called the
Word of Faith tradition and
Pentecostalism
that if you sort of ritually intone
mantras of success and victory and
triumph over adversity
God you know then he's you know as those
teen preachers there is a miracle in
your mouth
and you you know up until about 1985 you
could get arrested for that
exactly exactly well we have the Liberty
reinstating yes but word of faith comes
out of Pentecostalism which in the early
20th century was a millennialist
religious movement among overwhelmingly
poor dispossessed southern whites and
african-americans in Southern California
and this is Aimee Semple McPherson yeah
she could leave under a tight yes yeah
and so you have the end Aimee Semple
McPherson is a good sort of transitional
figure because she practiced in within
you know the limits of Southern
California at the time as a kind of
progressive social gospel she preached
to integrated congregations which was a
very big deal and she was a woman
herself she's a woman who shall show who
is not yea married which sort of became
a trouble spot later uh-huh because she
evidently took up with a married radio
producer and her Empire I mean and and
you know one of the I think the great
things of the book is that it is both an
incredible tour of 19th century America
as well as 20th and particularly in the
70s when kind of Pentecostalism or
evangeline evangelical christianity went
mainstream with jimmy carter with how
lindsay with all sorts of cultural
phenomenon but talk about how it blends
with capitalism that Wow that's you know
that's the interesting story so you do
have what's originally this movement of
you know that if you look at the broader
history of millennialist which is you
know in times two I believe it has been
throughout Western culture a movement of
the dispossessed so it becomes you know
in that hands of figures like Aimee
Semple McPherson this sort of faith of
the consumer marketplace McPherson was
famous for doing these radio plays about
her own misadventures you know being
stopped by a cop in Southern California
and she made herself you know this is
where you get the same idea of word of
faith like you you know the believing
self is occupied center stage and the
drama of salvation
you get you know God smiles upon you for
you know being his chosen prophet tests
in this case so you gradually shed a lot
and the seventies is a key moment in my
view because that is the moment of
crisis for you know sort of New Deal
liberalism growth and had never you call
it Keynesianism it well it's that the
post-war economic consensus right done
I'm working anymore right so yeah right
and so you know the the you have
stagflation you have a massive explosion
of interest rates you know the you know
the monetarist recession that Volcker
Institute's under Carter this you know
creates just massive crisis and people
are thrown onto their own resources and
particularly believing Protestants you
know need you know they both need a
direct infusion of the Holy Ghost which
is what the Pentecostal tradition is all
about so there need this sort of
experiential affirmation of their worth
at a time when the economy isn't giving
it to them and they also you know turn
to these prophets you know figures like
Hal Lindsey Maribel Morgan the under the
total woman in the domestic sphere there
is also this very you know overlooked
scholars like Bethany Morton have done a
very good work looking at how economic
relations in the domestic sphere get
reorganized and then as a service
economy which becomes the principal
source of economic growth in America
mobilizes all the the kind of servant
ethos a Protestant womanhood becomes
valuable it becomes a model of worker
discipline and there's a separate
movement in management theory called
servant leadership that comes that
creates a whole sort of cottage industry
and management spiritual management
traps that are all about how you have to
you know simultaneously you know
exemplify a spirit of humility in your
working life but also be intensely
disciplined and it's a very striking
thing going back to joel osteen he
simultaneously you know preaches for
workers a gospel of you know joyful
acceptance of workplace hierarchies you
know you if you embrace the
opportunities that god gives you you
will be rewarded you know in a you know
by a factor of 100 this is a this goes
back to oral roberts another 70's figure
you know one of the one of those strains
in this so you pull through is the idea
that this vision of christianity and
it's it's fundamentally a Protestant
version because it's kind of gnostic
it's direct unmediated contact where the
holy yeah but that it turns christianity
away and from a communitarian faith to a
very individualistic that i and so that
and that's where you know capitalism and
christianity and the making of the
american dream and your your take comes
in talked a little bit about how that
then reveals itself in economic or labor
market yeah yeah the point of facts you
know religion is the first deregulated
industry in America when the
Congregational Church in Massachusetts
Massachusetts was the last south state
established church and I broke up in
1820 which was at the height both of the
Second Great Awakening and what's called
the market revolution a time in American
economic life where you have these
massive infrastructure projects like the
Erie Canal like toll roads connecting
border cities and an explosion in
government debt and debt interestingly
at this moment be goes from being hated
at any cumulative phase of capitalism
which you know Max Weber describes in
the Protestant ethic and the spirit of
capitalism work becomes fetishized
it is a spiritual vocation it's the way
you know if you're an anxious Cal
the only thing you can know with
certainty is that you have a divine
calling and you would better do it
brother
and then maybe God will reward you in
the afterlife but not is so opaque and
angry there's no way of knowing I know
ultimately Americans can't stand that
because I know they wanted and they want
sir yes yeah immediacy so and that's the
second great awakening over Pharaohs
Calvinist right it's it's all about sort
of different competing visions of
universal salvation and freewill is the
huge kind of spiritual doctrine that
that overtakes American Protestantism
that which I would argue coincides
perfectly with the market revolution you
have new opportunities
that's pretty girly in urban centers
port cities and so I mean in that way
this vision of Christianity where you're
responsible for your own salvation it's
also in American society you're
responsible for your station in life you
either make it or don't on your own
merit right right yeah you're literally
your turn back on your own resource you
know that clearly seems true or it's a
tight reading of kind of a long sweep of
Protestant theology and the way it
affects American cultural identity
certainly through the 70s and into the
80s maybe in the 90s at this point in
time though is this a dead faith in you
know certainly the religious right and
somebody like Joel Osteen and in a sense
that you have to introduce him it makes
them different than maybe Oral Roberts
but certainly he's a norman vincent
peale
or earlier you know television or Billy
Graham everybody would know who they are
so is is this actually a going concern
no I think I think you know in an
interesting way it's it's succumbed to
certain forces of market fragmentation
right definitely you know Joel Osteen
you know it's worth he's not worth it
was north of 40 million dollars so he's
not yeah marginal figure Brian
I think he's theologically he's outside
the mainstream this whole you know word
of faith tradition is regarded with you
know great suspicion both from the right
and the left on the theological spectrum
but I would say that you know there if
anything figure
like we're gonna see a lot more Joel
Osteen's Joel Osteen and Donald Trump
are great friends Donald Trump was
allegedly you know brought into a
born-again experience by a prosperity
preacher Paul Wight in Florida and this
I grew up in by being norman vincent
peale right now there's a very good
actor line and it's and it's more in a
way it's I mean while it's still
pursuing a religious tract it's been a
highly secularized because this is the
Think and Grow Rich yeah secular is but
I sort of argue that what's happening
isn't religion is becoming more
scientific or secular or rational the
market is becoming an a mystical object
of worship the market is becoming
sanctified so that's Joel Osteen's God
is delivering all of his bounty in the
form of promotions wealth
new cars this is all very fragile Center
in this in the sermons and books that
stated well let's talk about the
unmaking of the American Dream and I
think in the book you won one way it's
just implied or taken for granted and
that's that where you know I don't know
if you subscribe to the phrase late
capitalism or advanced capitalism but
hey there's a you know there's a broad
sense while the middle class is finished
economic growth is a 2 percent if you're
lucky excetera that you kind of assume
that but then there's also the other way
which is that this is kind of a war of
all against all that the Solidarity of
the worker is gone right cetera so talk
a little bit about how you define the
unmaking of the american dream and then
how this line of thought is implicated
in the first thing I always say about
that phrase is that my agent wrote the
subtitle and presented it to me as a
fait accompli okay so I don't really
have a coherent theory worked out of
Dean and you can ask my agent but I do
think it's apt in certain ways and I
think what's striking is the facts you
know we did endure you know a crippling
recession in 2008
and from America you know the leading
pulpits in American Protestantism there
was almost no acknowledgement of this
you know massive change and you know
even when you apply it to things you
know this is not gonna be popular with
reason readers but the debate over the
ACA whatever you think about universal
health care it should be a lively
subject of debate in the Christian one
would think yeah right you're supposed
to care for the sick right
and it's driking nothing but is it also
true that protestants including you know
ministries like Osteen's and others and
i know some mega churches and in the
northern virginia actually do a huge
amount they do not really work they do a
lot of mission izing especially overseas
now there is always that tradition I
don't want to sell it short but you know
what I'm writing about is and even you
know I was what's interesting in in the
case of people like Osteen is charity to
is ultimately a way that you are you
know yes you're doing good works but
you're also going to get a and it return
on investment yeah so and you also see
it like you know again to you know it's
it's cheap and easy here in DC in 2016
to always talk about Donald Trump but I
am in DC in 2016 and I will talk about
it well Joe he the week after he made
his big pitch to a thousand evangelical
leaders and and really galvanized them
convinced them he was an ardent culture
warrior called himself a tremendous
believer because a huge is a big enough
yes and you'll notice the the Monday
after that the Washington Post had a
report that Trump was exaggerating the
volume of his charitable giving by a
factor of a couple hundred yeah that was
he was claiming to it's in the millions
it was in fact less than ten thousand
dollars over last yeah less than ten
thousand dollars over seven years so you
know you pan back and you ask you know
whatever else it is the idea that you're
you're kind of stiffing charitable
causes and then
lying about it jebadiah very human or
very American right and so you know that
is in a sense the problem I'm trying to
explain in the book how do you have this
you know guy who's now you know getting
real traction in the evangelical
community and you know he does not
embody the spirit of charity honesty or
anything else yeah well let's talk about
the Baffler for a moment and the you
know in whose pages I know I and other
reason authors and reason readers have
been the one Damaris points but no which
is fine but it's it's a classic sort of
what what used to be called a little
magazine cut not unlike reason that
punches far above its weight now the
question I wanted to ask as you've taken
over the editorship of it over the past
couple of years as it came back from a
kind of hiatus what do you hope to have
to do it the Baffler you know I I think
you know it's we were out to destroy
reason you know I want to make long-form
magazine journalism you know connect
with a new audience that occupies this
you know someone fragmented digital
media sphere you know I want the
bathroom to be the best Journal of
culture criticism in America I think you
know there's no reason you do something
like this unless you have a you know
sort of messianic as it were sense of
mission and I think you know I think we
want to shake up you know bland
orthodoxies across the spectrum do you
feel that the left is kind of on its
heels these days it depends you know
like everything else you have to define
your terms you can say like the Bernie
Sanders movement whatever else yeah you
know it it galvanized a big following of
you know impassioned younger activists
and voters what's interesting to me is
you had the saint structurally the same
thing happened within the Democratic
Party in 2008 and you know they found a
way to embrace that and this time they
have but is that because Barack Obama
was not really as radical or he didn't
talk the same way I mean he's very
centrist all ya know and he talked of
rudder
of radical procedural run you know we
are the change we've been waiting for it
did you know it's all about chocolate so
I talked about so well but yeah I do you
think you know there there is we
discussed this a lot it within the
Baffler world that you know there for a
an intellectual community that sort of
prides itself on iconoclasm and and
smashing you know traditions or whatever
there's there's a lot of high ban
orthodoxy on the left there are things
you're not supposed to say and think and
you know anytime i'm you know this is
just my temperament anytime I'm told
you can't think something I I'm
determined to think it that that much
okay so let me make a final pitch
because I bet you know and and this is
something I mean I think the book is
fantastic and it's just like even in the
parts that I don't agree with I had
learned so much and and remembered so
much from history so you know just
phenomenal that way and the Baffler
which I read but I disagree with almost
every comma every you know every dawn I
think we but it's you've got that over
up for all of the differences in
worldview and temperament between say
like a Baffler left and a reason
libertarian reason because alou you know
there are all different types of people
there's a lot of issues in which the you
know kind of broadly defined libertarian
libertarian right and maybe libertarian
left or left or an agreement you know
that the that centrist groups in the
Republican Democratic parties are
useless they're contemptible they need
to be removed for power that cronyism
whether it's government contracts or
corporate cronyism is a real problem
foreign policy is almost always stupidly
taken you know it's conceived poorly and
then ineffective in application and that
things like cultural expression are more
important or precede political action or
inform it you know what are the areas in
which these kinds of overlaps can you
know is there a coalition to be had
between
kind of libertarian right and a
progressive left or uh you know and
where does that happen
III may represent that coalition because
I think I'm the only person to have
contributed both to the Baffler and
reason yes yeah so you're looking at it
oh we've got to go out get you out I
think things like foreign policy are
definitely and I area okay I think most
of the things you've listed I think you
know there's a shared contempt for
difference trimming of like neoliberal
centrism on the Democratic side and you
know I don't even know what to say about
the Republicans saying a party that is
in the process of I just not you know
dramatic reinvention oh yeah they're
they're molting very different in a few
you but yeah I think you know there is
and there are some respects in which you
know I'm you know I think Loftus should
have a suspicion of the state you know
all institutions are you know
reflections of human nature which is a
flawed material to live with but we'll
end it with that in the invocation of a
basic Christian are you guys I often say
you know I'm not a believer and you know
when you're not a believer in salvation
but you are in a recession yeah well we
will leave it there we've been talking
with Chris Laban he's the author most
recently of the excellent book the money
called capitalism Christianity and the
unmaking of the American Dream Chris
thanks for talking to thanks for having
me for reason TV I'm Nick Gillespie